so
yeah absolutely
um all right hello everyone thanks for
making it here on a
nice crisp berkeley morning uh it's my
pleasure to introduce david gamanick who
until very recently was my only office
mate and now i have an empty office
which is me
um
and he's going to tell us about a
curious case of a symmetric binary
perceptron so take it away david
thank you ashwin uh
and yeah good good to see everybody well
good to sort of see
you i uh missed
already great interactions at simon's i
had to be back for for teaching and i
only wish i could spend uh the whole
semester there as many of you uh do so
enjoy it
while you can
um
it's uh uh it's a pleasure to to to to
share with you some uh recent work it's
actually work in progress and i'll i'll
uh i'll explain what part of it is still
in progress as as as we progress uh no
pun intended um
and it's called the curious case of the
symmetric binary perceptron model
uh i will explain what's curious about
that this is a joint work with with
aaron kiseldak um my student at mit he
should be somewhere in the audience so
okay good
right so aaron okay uh so if there's any
uh questions from the audience aaron
will be happy to answer them
um
who is a postdoc at harvard and will
perkins
from the university of illinois in
chicago uh
most of you probably know uh well very
well okay um
my battery is almost dead so just just
just a second okay
just like uh yesterday's lenka talk i i
want to start by acknowledging
by acknowledging uh georgia parisi
receiving a
nobel prize that's an incredible
news for us as
needless to say georgia is an incredible
uh contributor to the field to our field
so it's not just physics but but his
name has been mentioned many many times
in this and previous workshops because
of his fantastic contribution to the
structural and algorithmic ideas in the
random structures in uh
and optimization
and this this this work is actually not
uh not an exception for that and uh so i
thought as my own tribute to to georgia
i'll do my own
rendition of his
of uh of his
picture so
i have to say that my my handwriting
skills is not that good so
but my drawing skills are even worse so
you use them
[Laughter]
maybe i'll i'll i'll give him a little
bow tie i think it's appropriate so all
right so
great great great news okay now slightly
and more serious note uh
there's a word percept on in the thai in
uh in the title
um
just a brief history of that arguably
perceptron is the marks the birth of the
machine learning field it was introduced
in by frank rosen
rosenblatt from the university of
cornell in 1958 and it was supposed to
it was implemented on this little
machine
uh in ibm a little machine you can
imagine it's several rooms large
and it was supposed to do the
recognition face recognition or i think
or maybe uh some kind of an image
recognition i don't remember
and it was uh
arguably the births that marked the
birth of the machine learning field this
was so amazing that back then the new
york times wrote an article about that
and and i i quote here new york times
reported that the perceptron will be the
embryo of an electronic computer that
the navy
uh of all things expects to be able to
walk talk see write reproduce itself and
conscience of its existence and this is
1958 so as you can see the the doomsday
scenarios of of uh machines overtaking
overtaking humans is not something new
it goes back uh
ages um
um anyways a little bit of history uh on
that
and back to our business don't worry
this is not gonna be an applied stock
it's we're going to just talk
theory
right a little just a little digression
okay so let me introduce the model
uh the binary perceptron model so it's
binaries in reference to the solution
space being a binary cube so we're going
to fix a binary cube of n dimensions
okay
then we fix a matrix
which is m by n
a matrix uh we also fixed a subset of a
set of real values r
uh and our goal uh
goal is to find sigma in uh in the
binary cube such that a
so when we hit this matrix with with
vector uh sigma uh it it lies in the set
c to the power n
so in other words for every row when you
hit it with the vector sigma it belongs
to the set of c
and the two common uh examples that that
have been considered in the literature
and the ones we will consider today are
are this the following special cases
this case one
and this is going to be the main focus
of today is uh when c is just a
symmetric interval around zero
and we will refer to it as a symmetric
binary perceptron model but i will also
mention uh
another case case two when when c is
just a set of non-negative reals which
is refer to asymmetric
binary perceptron model
okay so in the in this case you need to
find the vector sigma such that
a of sigma
in l infinity norm
is in the interval from kappa minus
kappa to kappa and i will also use uh
i will also use the normalization
square root n normalization in
anticipation of the scaling that we will
be interested in
um and that that's a natural scaling to
do uh you we will see why all right so
just algorithmically you have a matrix
you have a set you want to find a binary
vector such that when you hit the matrix
uh with this vector it lies in some
subspace of euclidean space
and
that's the that's the problem no
naturally we will
we will focus on the case of the random
random
instances
and
in
random instances we are interested in
the cases where entries of the matrix
are either
normal standard normal
or
they are rather
rather
okay
plus minus one with probability one half
so
and then the variables i will freely go
between the two uh cases
uh because for most of the party
wouldn't matter the details of the
distribution for many of the things i'm
about to say wouldn't uh don't matter
in some cases uh they do it's not
surprising that many of the things are
uh
exhibit exhibit universality property
where the details of the distributions
are irrelevant as long as the first two
moments match the first moment here
being zero of course so uh if you have
this model in mind then the copper being
constant
uh kappa being constant makes sense
because if you take a matrix a 1 over
square root n times sigma then each
row
then and you get a vector each entry of
this vector is going to be standard uh
normal if aij is standard normal so you
want to make sure that all of such
standard normals are in the interval
between minus
kappa and kappa and of course that's
automatically wouldn't be wouldn't be
the case because uh the extreme of the
gaussian is like square root log n so
it's not by no means obvious that such a
thing
is possible
okay so that's the
this is the model and the questions we
wanted we want to ask are fairly
standard questions that we ask in this
conference so the first questions of
existence
and let me introduce the notation let
sigma of a
uh and the underlying set where
we want uh
the vector to be is i'm not gonna
make it part of notation this is all
sigma in a binary cube
such that a sigma is
normalized by square root n
is in the set whatever
whatever set we care
about okay so it is it's a set uh
of satisfying vectors satisfying
solutions
satisfying
solutions
all right so the questions of existence
is that is a
uh empty or not
and that's the first question and the
second question is algorithms if we
somehow know that such a set is uh
non-empty can we actually find uh such
effect
okay and because this solution space is
here is binary it's not obvious a priori
is that such a thing can be done as
opposed to the classical rosenblatt's uh
case
where
if there's a linear separator you can
actually find it
in by many ways all right so this is
this is the model it obviously goes
without saying if you have any questions
about
the model
go ahead i hope the model is clear but
any questions
on the model before i turn over and and
and
share with you what we know
about this model mostly i will talk
about the symmetric case so let me
actually start now with the
give you some background
and for the symmetric
case so in this
uh this means that we want to all
entries of the vector to be in the
interval minus kappa to kappa so first
um so we're going to consider
for both symmetric and asymmetric case
we're going to consider the proportional
regime
regime and that means that m the number
of rows
above rows
is going to be some alpha times n which
is the number of columns and l alpha is
going to be fixed
and so what do we know about that the
fairly straightforward argument shows
that
that
this solution
is empty
with high probability if alpha is bigger
than alpha critical and alpha critical
is actually log 2 divided by absolute
value of log kappa
okay
in particular it scales like order 1
over log kappa so where is this coming
from it comes from a very
straightforward
analysis you all together you have two
to the n
solutions in the binary uh in the binary
space
and you look at the problem oh not sorry
i made a mistake here i made a mistake
it's a bit premature the denominator
here is the probability that absolute
value of the gaussian is at most kappa
okay so i jumped too fast so
david we need an extra logo
i'm sorry we need an extra loop in the
denominator thank you
thank you yes so this comes from
absolutely so this comes from uh from
the fact that okay uh
each row upon hitting with with with the
binary vector becomes a gaussian this
gaussian needs to be in the interval so
you have this condition and all of this
needs to happen uh for the alpha times
n uh different rows on the other hand
you have two to the n different
solutions so you want to at the very
least make sure that this goes to
infinity as n goes to infinity uh and if
alph and alpha critical is reversed
engineered from that so if alpha is
bigger than one the expected number of
solution goes to zero so that's not
that's kind of
obvious um
but what is not uh obvious is actually
this
this alpha uh critical is alpha critical
is tight
and this is a fairly recent result
by um
by xu jung jiksu and perkins
or perkins xu i'm sorry if i
change the ordering inadvertently so and
simultaneously abe
li and and sly
also about same year they have shown
that in fact
alpha
critical is tight
and what it means is that uh the
probability that the solution space is
non-empty
non-empty actually goes to 1 as n goes
to infinity when alpha is less than
alpha critical
um
now
that sort of comes from the second
moment analysis but not quite the second
moment analysis gives you that this
probability is bounded away from zero
but if you actually want to argue the
tightness of that you have to do more
work and this is what has been done
uh but something else really interesting
i think emerged in these two pieces of
work
and that has to do with the
clustering uh picture
the familiar clustering picture that we
keep discussing in the context of
various constraint satisfaction problems
um and we can think of this also maybe
as a constraint satisfaction problem so
um what what they have uh discovered it
is the following so horizontal line will
correspond to alpha
uh alpha you have alpha critical here
actually let me move it a little a
little further okay
so you have alpha critical here
uh and here that corresponds to the
onset
regime
um what they have define uh discovered
perhaps not surprisingly that that
before the alpha critical there is if
the solution space
is split um
into clusters
uh not the entire solution space
most of the solution space and i will
explain
i'll explain
okay
so what i have discovered
uh is that
somewhat more more more formally
you can find
you can find a subset sigma hat over
sigma which is almost the entire space
so the ratio of sigma hat over over
sigma
is
at least one minus exponentially small
in the number of uh in the number of
columns
uh such that in this subset
uh all solutions are in fact singletons
so that's why i draw them as little dots
as opposed to circles single tones
separated by extensive differences of
order n
okay
now that is in reference to that is in
reference
to this big subset of the solution space
it arg immediately almost the entire
solution space but not everything which
means that potentially if you
if uh you include everything else that
has been omitted in this solution space
then this is no longer true and you can
have some little like tunnels here
connecting uh various uh singletons
but modular this exception
this model exhibits an extreme form of
clustering where each cluster actually
consists of a single dot uh
alternatively you can say that the
number of rows the percentage of frozen
variables uh variables
is uh 100. in this is in references of
so-called frozen variables in clusters
maybe not not something familiar to all
of you but but if you've seen this stuff
before uh you you know what i mean
now here's the most this is perhaps not
surprising the most surprising thing
about this
is that that actually happens above zero
so this picture of this
described holds for
this picture i have described holds for
for
every positive alpha
and you can contrast it with the picture
that you see in the random k-set model
and i want to do this
uh i want to do this comparison and and
i will explain why i think it's an
interesting comparison
okay but before i do that you might ask
and we'll come back to that
whether there exists a different face
where this clustering does occur
that should be at a higher threshold
value where this clustering occurs
and
without without exception
is that the case or not
i'm asking that because
that is the case for the random k-set
model so first any any questions about
what i
drew here so this picture is an
implication of this uh two pieces of
work by
sue perkinson abele and and sply
okay
now
let me remind you what what we know
for a related similar problem of the
random k-set
random case
problem
okay so again we have a critical alpha
i'm not going to define what random case
that is so i'm gonna i'm kind of hoping
that many of you have seen this uh this
before again there is a phase which is
on set
and there is uh
but
now the onset of clustering so call it
cluster
unlike in the perceptron model happens
at the positive density
so
you have
uh which means that below that the
solution space is mostly
connected maybe there's some exceptions
here and there but it's mostly connected
whereas here
the solution space is most of it
disconnected
disconnected by order and distances
so you have clusters the clusters are no
longer singleton so it's not 100 of
variables are frozen most of them are
frozen
and
and that again applies to the majority
of variables uh and majority of solution
space which means that
some tunnels between the clusters
uh might occur
but in fact
probably there is another phase here
uh another phase
and actually let me let me call this
type of face as a weak
clustering
and let me call this
strong clustering so strong is is in
reference to no exceptions
so in this phase what do we have
uh
in this case we have these clusters of
solutions
but there is no tunnels between them
probably
all hundred percent of the solution
space is clustered
what's the relevance of this and and and
why am i spending so much time on that
the relevance of this is the
potential algorithmic implication of all
of this
for the case of the random k-set model
random k-set model
there is a fairly strong evidence
then algorithm that that the algorithmic
hardness occurs actually here at the
onset of the weak clustering the most
recent
uh
confirmation of that uh is is in the
work of
uh guy bressler and and bryce huang of
this year
who showed that pretty tightly at this
threshold
many of the algorithms that we know like
low degree polynomials that algorithms
fail
okay
and that that's not very surprising this
pic this this this this line has been
conjectured to be the onset of the
algorithmic hardness
a while ago already so that's not a
surprise
um okay so it presumably weak clustering
property is the onset of hardness if
that's the case if we go back to the
perceptron model
maybe the problem is hard for every
positive density alpha
and that's the curious part of this talk
the answer is no
there are there exists positive alpha
for which the problem is solvable
so let me
let me
uh
share with you what we know about
okay
so the answer is no um how do we know
that first
a while ago
in the heuristic
study the empirical study by brownstein
and zekina
and this is
all six
they they did experiments uh and this
experiments revealed that that it seems
at least experimentally that the
perceptron model is solvable at some
small but positive density
uh even though we know now that the it
exhibits a clustering
okay but then later this was confirmed
and the paper that the most relevant uh
for us today that i will spend more time
uh on is
is by bonsall
and spencer
uh bansal and spencer appeared in 20
posted a little earlier and uh
the bonsai and pape spencer
uh
work
shows that indeed
there exists a positive alpha
for which this symmetric so this is in
reference to the symmetric
model
so we have kappa here
that for each
um
uh the critical kappa
has to be at least as large as something
and and and you can show that there's
something as as
in size of the interval goes to zero
is actually quadratic in kappa squared
quadratic in kappa
okay
so it's a positive result they construct
an algorithm very clever one uh
that uh shows that that indeed symmetric
perceptron model uh is solvable at some
positive density the critical value uh
here therefore for the symmetric
perceptron model is at least order kappa
squared
so that at the very least i guess
suggests that
showing this picture that we have here
as an evidence of the algorithmic
hardness in other words the onset of
weak clustering as evidence of
algorithmic hardness that
that
flies in the face of of the uh
of this
of this picture where we have the weak
clustering occurring
in uh at every positive density
yet there are algorithms to solve this
so let me pause here before i sort of
recollect my thought let me pause here
and ask if you have
any questions
okay
um
so
all right by
this is not an exhaustive list of the um
positive results on um
on the symmetric uh perceptron model in
fact there is an earlier work by
by lovett
lovett
and um mecca
uh
from 15
they also
construct an an algorithm that solves
the symmetric
uh binary perceptron model uh
but their analysis seems to be applying
only in the case where the number of
rows
is bigger than uh number of
columns
and that cannot therefore from that it's
hard to figure out what's the
implication when kappa
goes to zero because if if kappa goes to
zero uh
that the only the critical uh alpha goes
to zero as well that means that you have
to work with way fewer rows than columns
and that kind of makes sense if you want
all your
answers to be in a tiny little intervals
you cannot afford to have too many rows
uh in in your matrix so let's let's
let's summarize so what do what do we
have first we have a critical
alpha so this is in again in symmetric
binary perceptron model we have a
critical alpha c which
looks
like like like this it's log 2
divided by the log
of the probability that standard
gaussian is at most kappa
so we're going to
call it alpha c of kappa
ah as kappa goes to 0
this
becomes approximately log 2 divided by
the log
kappa absolute value
so
let's keep this scaling in in place
okay
so this is
as far as the existential result is
concerned on the other hand as as i said
as i said by bansal and spencer
uh
the implication is is that
when as long as alpha is less than or
equal to something of order kappa
squared
the solution
is non-empty with high probability
so there is still a big gap between
kappa squared
and log 2 and something which is here
which is order
order
1 over log
kappa
absolute value
so the the positive results exist up to
here existentially we we have it up to
here so we have a gap
right so clustering uh aside we have a
gap and can we explain this gap
some uh some way and that's what i want
to
report we're going to take
surprise surprise we're going to take
the approach of the overlap gap property
which i will explain
uh shortly
uh as a side remark there is a reading
group uh now ongoing assignments by
bryce
and aaron
uh on this so if you wanted to know more
about this i would refer you to the
to this reading uh group so we want to
take the overlap gap uh property or
another or put it more generally the a
different landscape
uh
uh
approach to try in to try to understand
the true algorithmic uh hardness uh of
this problem
okay
uh right so here's what what uh what we
know let me state it in a
theorem this is going to be likely the
only theorem
that i'm going to formally state
it's going to be long i bear with me uh
uh please uh
and but but then i'll stay the theorem
formally i i hope it's it's
it's correctly stated aaron will correct
me if something is not accurate and then
i'll give the intuition
so here
we take the kind of full
sort of power of the ogp
approach
the theorem is
stating that that a model exhibits the
so-called symmetric
and sampler
ensemble
multi
multi ogp
probably very little of this makes sense
uh at this stage but i'll explain
okay
so um
recall we're dealing with a symmetric
model so we have parameter kappa
so the claim is that
for every
small enough
kappa
there exists
a critical number let me call it known
creatively as alpha ogp of kappa
it's going to be certainly less than
critical value
for the existence of the solution
uh
i'll say much more about that how much
below it is
such that the following is true
for however
if it takes alpha slightly larger than
the critical value
ah
i apologize i have to i have to do the
digression into uh
okay sorry sorry i have to i have to
first introduced an ensembler version uh
of the uh of the model
so i'm gonna
i guess i'll come back to the theorem
and and introduce the
uh
and assembler model
i will do it only for the case of the
standard
normals
so every entry of the matrix is standard
normal
so
here's what we're gonna do
let's create an another matrix a hat
which is independent from the original
matrix a
and let's create an an interpolated
family of models a of t
which is
defined as follows it's a cosine of t
times a plus sine of t
times uh
times
a hat
okay
so in other words we have a
one matrix
we have another matrix
this is a
this is a hat
and now we create this whole family of
matrices
a of t
in between
and one thing to observe is that entries
of each of such matrix are again
standard normal
because
the variances
match
okay so
that's what we have so we we have this
interpolated uh family of models
uh and the theorem is in reference to
this interpolated family
what's the significance and so on that's
that's to be discussed but let me now uh
state the theorem so for every alpha
larger than this claimed value
there exists a large enough constant
integer constant m
such that
i'm reaching the limit of the number of
quantifiers that i've ever had to use
before
and more quantifiers are coming there
exists a number m such that
for every sequence of numbers starting
from
uh
0 up to pi over 2 y pi over 2 because
uh
st is equal to 0 in this interpolated
family we have the first matrix and when
t is equal to pi over 2
we have the in the new freshly
independent matrix so this interval
uh goes as t spans
from zero to pi
over two
okay
uh all right so
if you fix any time instances
in in this interval
uh so there for the existing m such that
i made a mistake for every sequence of
such numbers and for every
um
sequence of solutions uh sigma 1 in
instance associated with time 1
sigma 2
in instance a satisfying assignment with
respect to the instance
at time 2 and so on
sigma m associated with the satisfying
assignment
at time t m
that exists
[Music]
okay and
all right something else is missing here
there exists
m
and two numbers nu1
mu2 less than one
such that any time you have this it is
also the case that there exists
two numbers okay and
um
l between
1
and m
such that the inner product of sigma
k
and sigma l
normalized by n
belongs
to either
the interval from zero to new one or
interval from uh
u2
let me
write it cleanly mu2 to 1
okay
now if you were able to parse what i
have here
upon seeing something like this for the
first time i would be hugely impressed
because this is
probably nearly impossible to say what
what this even says let alone understand
its significance or
implication
so now let me try to
yes
where's the uh probabilistic quantifier
i mean where do i oh good good i i miss
that there exists uh
there exists so that that existence is
with high probability
before picking the
the a
the endpoints are after or
i think the
with respect to the randomness of the a
and independent copy of a once you fix a
and fix a copy of a the interpolated
family is deterministic is well
conditionally deterministic and that's
in reference to this render that's the
only randomness
they happen at the end so
this prohibited
v1 v2 is chosen before choosing uh
ah okay good thanks for asking i think
it's nazi right if i'm not if i'm
here
okay so the all of these parameters are
deterministic
new one is this all of these parameters
alpha of our gp
uh nu1 and u2 and m these are all
uh m
mu1 u2 are all deterministic
they're fixed up before
deterministic meaning only kappa
dependent but nothing else dependent
k and l are they also deterministic or
can ill depend on
no no they're not they're not uh
okay no
no they might they might depend on how
you actually drawn
such solutions sigma so you
you you fix any collection of times
let me come back to that maybe when i
try to give some intuition
if that's if that's okay and maybe that
will clarify uh also what is random and
non-random here
okay so what is
uh
what is uh happening here first the as a
as a warm up
as a warm up let's consider the case
where
m is equal to two
and we just speak
two identical times t zero is equal to t
one did i start with t zero or t one
doesn't probably matter t one okay uh so
let's
suppose we just look at the
special case when two times are equal to
zero in other words we're just dealing
with a single instance uh a case
so the implication of that uh that is
very simple as long as you take two
satisfying
uh solutions in the symmetric perceptron
model it should be the case that their
inner product
normalized
by n
is either in
uh 0 from nu1
or
mu2 to 1 in other words exhibits a gap
and geometrically that's that's very
simple that basically says that
that okay so pairwise distances for
every
for every two solutions pairwise
distances uh have to be either
small or large so pairwise
uh distances
uh small
quote unquote or
large quote unquote
okay so that was
easy but i i realize it doesn't quite
answer the question that nettie has uh
raised so let me now
come back to the the theorem and now in
the pictorial way
so here's what we do sort of he's the
sort of dynamically sort of what happens
withdraw
and in the in a copy of a
that's a random copy we draw another
copy of
of the same
randomness a hat which is independent
we construct a sequence
continuous sequence
of
um
models so in uh parameterized by
time continuous time going from zero to
pi over two
so each of this corresponds to a of t
fine
okay
now
uh
right so then we we fix
fix any
numbers t1 and so on tm
so in other words we fix
collection of instances here maybe this
one this one and and this one
any m instances in this in continuous
family
we pick for each instance
we pick any
uh
solution so sigma 1 is in
here
and and and so on
sigma m is in
satisfying solution with respect to the
m uh instance
those could be picked arbitrarily as
long as they are in a satisfying
in a satisfying set
so those are peaks so we pick the vector
here we
associate with this instance a vector
associated with this instance the vector
associated with the instance so we have
the whole bunch of vectors in the binary
binary cube one vector sigma 1
sigma 2
sigma 3 and so on sigma m
we look at the pairwise distances
all m choose 2 of them and all we're
saying is that there are should be two
instances
just two of them
for which
the distance or the overlap
is
not
in the intermediate
uh interval from u1 and u2
net is this good enough
i just can you bring this sorry sorry at
least me is mu 1 and mu 2 the period is
dependent on m or is it
can you show the theorem again please
just uh the quantifiers you scroll back
to all the quantifiers
yes uh uh right
yeah exist m and u1 and u2 so both m and
u1 and u2 depend on kappa
okay all right so i'm i know i'm running
out of time but let me tell you the
punch line of all of this well there is
actually two two punch lines one is not
very surprising to many people in the
audience one is perhaps surprising
so
uh
first is that
why would why would we care about
structure like that because using this
structure we can rule out classes of
algorithms
and
and that holds here as well so the
presence of this multi-symmetric
multi-ensemble ogp
rules out
uh stable algorithms
items
now
one
uh
there's two algorithm one algorithm i
didn't mention earlier
is
it's for the literally for the
asymmetric model kim and rouge we can
prove that this algorithm is stable
although it applies to asymmetric model
not symmetric models so its implication
is not entirely clear
uh bonsall and spencer
algorithm appears to be symmetric this
is the work in progress uh
and but we believe we have an idea to
show that in fact it's symmetric but the
implication is there so once the
multi-presence of the structure can be
used to rule out algorithms
this is not very surprising perhaps the
the normal part an interesting part is
that if you work out the critical kappa
um
sorry so so here we have critical uh if
you work out for which
kappa um
for
for each kappa for small enough copper
where is the onset
of the overlapping property
that turns out to be kappa
2
minus little of one
and if you contrast it with this bandsaw
and spencer algorithm that works
up to kappa squared
so in this
landscape uh in in this one-dimensional
parameter remember the critical is
something of the order one of the log
kappa
the
algorithm exists so uh
the algorithm exists by bansal and
spencer
when kappa is when alpha is of the order
kappa squared but pretty much
immediately after that
uh
we have the ogp regime
indicating that
likely the problem is hard
so the ogp picture here provides a
fairly tight uh
fairly tight
characterization
tied with respect to the known
algorithmic uh
threshold
okay i i think i'm over my time so
perhaps i should stop here and take
questions
so this characterizes
the difference between weak clustering
and the strong quest clustering
good good so no neither so let me
actually you remind me thank you
i think it was me close uh thank you for
reminding me that
so
the multi-ogp picture by itself
is not this
is not
i don't know how to describe it in terms
of the clustering property of a kind
however
the if you look at the two or gp
so in the case where at least two pair
by solutions are
in a product is disconnected the onset
of the two rgp implies
implies strong uh
implies strong clustering so and what it
means is that in in this context
remember i posed this as a
as a question mark there is no question
mark so we know that
there exists a strong
uh clustering
uh property
uh clustering property for the symmetric
binary perceptron model
it does happen but it happens not at the
algorithmic threshold it happens much at
a larger value at least
for computation at the values larger
than than kappa squared we don't know
what exactly how it scales with kappa
but it doesn't doesn't get
get all the way to the algorithm
threshold and the algorithm threshold is
somewhere here
which is again it's it's hard to connect
it with a clustering picture per se
thanks so so this so the 200 gp and this
mogp
would be different thresholds oh yes
yeah that's that's the that right sorry
for not
clarifying that the the reason we needed
to go and and this is historically let
me actually mention several pieces of
work i mean
meant to uh mention in reference to the
multi ogp picture
one is by
lx1 in the context of independent set
i mentioned already
bressler
and huang
in context of the k-set
and there is a more recent work which i
i guess will be posted soon by
bryce and
mark uh silk
in the context of p-spin
in all of these papers
the multi-ogp
structure is introduced and proven in
order to match the algorithmic threshold
and multi-ogp does occur at the
threshold lower
than the 200 gp
great thank you
hey great talk
um can you give some intuition for what
benzal spencer is doing and like maybe
how it's navigating the um
good
um
right so um
not going to have time to go into
details of the algorithm but let me
describe it in high level terms but you
also remind me something else i wanted
to mention it is
not worthy that both kim and rosh
algorithm that i barely mentioned here
but
also bonsal and spencer
algorithms
they are not instantiations of the low
degree polynomials
otherwise our work will be easier
because we already know how to rule out
law degree polynomials
they are not so we have to conduct an
independent stability analysis of that
so banzal and spencer algorithm works
like this
so you have a matrix
this is matrix a
so you have columns you essentially set
up values so for each associated with
each column you need to
set up the value
of the sigma which should be plus minus
one
essentially you do it in the dynamic uh
way
from the left to the right where you
sequentially set each of the values of
of the sigma
based on the values of what you've seen
up to uh that point so it's a online
effectively one sweep online uh
algorithm and this value sigma is
obtained well there's some potential
function analysis but basically what you
do is that you look at the values
corresponding to the sums across
previous t minus one columns
and then you set your value plus minus
one depending uh
based on this sign of the sum of those
of those values
it's not
not a very
description of the algorithm i i
realized but this is basically what's
going on it's just it's a one sweep
algorithm setting the values of the of
of sigma one by one
depending what you've seen before
um all right so for further questions
you can get in touch with david uh later
on but let's thank him again
[Applause]
17.